[موسيقى]
انا حاليا يعني انتقلت لرسم على الايباد
او الرسم الرقمي وانا حاليا يعني برسم
لوحات رقميه وبرسم لوحات عن طريق الزوم او
رسم الزوم يعني يعني هو لغه عالميه لذلك
انا بعتبر رسم من اقوى اسريه بالفن اثرا
على المشاهد يعني ترشحي لسفير نوال الحسنه
للاتحاد الاوروبي يعني صراحه خلاني اعطاني
كبير انه استمر في العمل الانساني وانه
استمر في في جميع الوسائل اللي انا بقدر
امثل فيها فلسطين
[موسيقى]
انا عز الدين لولو طالب طب بشريه سنه
رابعه في الجامعه الاسلاميه وفنان تشكيلي
عايش في فلسطين في قطاع غزه المحاصر بحب
ارسم اعبر عن افكار من خلال المحتوى الفني
الذي يقدمه دايما بحاول اوظف موهبه لتمثيل
بلده فلسطين في جميع الوسائل المتاحه
بدات بصراحه وانا عمري سبع سنين كانت في
البدايه رسومات
كرتونيه طفوليه في المنطقه
[تصفيق]
الشرقيه
في مؤتمر الطفوله اربعه في اسطنبول لكن
بسبب اغلاق المعابر ما قدرت اطلع واا طلعت
عن طريق بث مباشر رسم لوحه فنيه امام
الجمهور عن طريق اللايف
[موسيقى]
حصلت على مركز الثالث على مستوى الوطن
العربي في مسابقه الدوليه لرسم
كاريكاتير انا حاليا يعني انتقلت لرسم على
الايباد او الرسم الرقمي وانا حاليا يعني
برسم لوحات رقميه وبرسم لوحات عن طريق
رسم الزوم يعني يعني هو لغه عالميه لو
لذلك انا بعتبر رسم من اقوى اسريه بالفن
اثرا على المشاهدين وهذا يعني لاحظته في
الفتره الاخيره
على قطاع غزه
رسمه عده مشاهد ما كانت منتشره في هذا
العدوان عن طريق الزووم كنت انتقل من مشهد
لمشهد وكنت حاطط موسيقى حزينه بحيث
الموسيقى تعبر عن هذه المشاعر والحمد لله
خلال يوم واحد حصل على اكثر من مليون
مشاهده وهذا يعني يدل على على مدى انتشار
او مدى قوه تاثير هذا الرسم على جميع
الناس سواء في الوطن العربي او في الوطن
العربي يعني
[موسيقى]
الرسم صراحه يعني قبل ان يكون من اي شيء
ثاني هو فن والفن لا يوصل صور رساله
انسانيه يعني فمن هذا المنطلق بدات اركز
على فئات معينه من المجتمع فئات يستحقون
منها كل التقدير والاحترام كان اولهم
الشرطي واخرهم بائع الترمس الذي انتشر قبل
عده ايام يعني بصراحه اكثر من مره
كان دائما يعني بيشتغل من يعرقش بينه حبي
الفرحه والسرور على قلب هذا الشخص ويعني
الحمد لله كانت فعلا من اجمل رده فعل انا
شفته في حياتي
[موسيقى]
مؤشرات اللهم صل على سيدنا محمد
ممكن يقدر يساعده تم التواصل معه وتم
مساعدته الحمدالله
[موسيقى]
في الفتره الاخيره تم ترشحي من ضمن ست
مرشحين على مستوى فلسطين من صناعي المحتوى
في مسابقه الاتحاد الاوروبي
يتم اختيار صفراء النوايا الحسنه للاتحاد
الاوروبي
ترشحي لسفير النوايا الحسنه للاتحاد
الاوروبي يعني صلاح حسن خلاني اعطاني دافع
كبير انه استمر في العمل الانساني وانه
استمر في في جميع الوسائل اللي انا بقدر
امثل فيها فلسطين
بانه اواخر لهم الفرص اللي بيقدمها
الاتحاد الاوروبيه بحيث انه جميع المواهب
في قطاع غزه
صوتهم الى خارج فلسطين
[موسيقى]
من خلال التواصل الاجتماعي ايحاب اوصل
رساله الى جميع احر العالم فلسطين وشاب
قطاع غزه يستحق الحريه ويستحق الكرامه وان
اطفال ونساء غزه لازم يعيش زيهم زي اي حدا
حول العالم
[موسيقى]
يستمر في توصيل القضيه الفلسطينيه الى
جميع انحاء العالم وكل احد لازم يقاوم
بطريقه سواء في الرسم سواء في الشهر سواء
في الغناء سواء في الدبكه
[موسيقى]